[Música]
un día histórico áfrica venció a la
polio después de décadas de lucha
se trata de un virus infeccioso que
ataca a la médula espinal causando una
parálisis irreversible en los niños
after the world después de cuatro años
sin un caso de polio la región de áfrica
finalmente ha sido declarada libre de
polio miel y pollo barras
la polio fue endémica hasta 1950 cuando
se encontró una vacuna una solución que
quedó lejos de áfrica hasta este 2020 en
el que sólo se han registrado casos en
afganistán y pakistán
[Música]
tras una fecha histórica para el
feminismo se cumplen 50 años de la
fundación del movimiento de liberación
de las mujeres en francia
una lucha que empezó con la legalización
del aborto y que actualmente centra sus
esfuerzos contra el acoso
queríamos que las mujeres se pudieran
liberar de las leyes que eran cadenas
también de la violencia vimos en qué
punto estábamos y que pudiésemos afirmar
no si existir finalmente nos permitía
crear
existe
son muchos avances en los últimos 50
años cuando el mayo del 68 lo cambió
todo y llegó una lucha por los derechos
que todavía no ha terminado
[Música]
una medida para reducir la brecha
digital argentina de un paso más para
que nadie pueda quedar desconectado así
lo anunció el presidente alberto
fernández hemos decidido declarar
servicios públicos a la telefonía
celular a los servicios de internet ya
la televisión paga de esta manera
garantizamos el acceso de los mismos
para todos y todas
con esta iniciativa argentina trata de
preservar derechos como la educación el
acceso al conocimiento a la cultura y a
la comunicación
[Música]
un ejemplo de colaboración ciudadana en
berlín los residentes pueden ayudar a
que los árboles soporten las extremas
temperaturas del verano la plataforma
agua al capo tiene un mapa interactivo
con 625 mil árboles donde se muestra el
tipo la edad y las necesidades de agua
me duele el alma cuando veo que un árbol
se seca cuando pierde sus hojas cuando
ya no puede existir cuando los arbustos
mueren y cuando todo se seca
cada vez que un berlinés riega un árbol
puede apuntarlo en la plataforma un
intercambio de información que trata de
evitar que se pierdan 7000 árboles como
ocurrió entre 2016 y 2019
[Música]
un héroe anónimo en guatemala' ixcoy
conocido como profe lalito se compró una
bicicleta la adaptó como un triciclo con
pizarra y se fue casa por casa de sus 10
alumnos para que no perdieran sus clases
un compromiso para hacer posible la
educación
[Música]